[Music]
over 100,000 metric tons of caffeine are
consumed around the world every year
that's equivalent to the weight of 14 I
fault hours most of this caffeine is
consumed in coffee and tea but it's also
ingested in some sodas chocolate
caffeine pills and even beverages
labelled decaf caffeine helps us feel
alert focused happy and energetic even
if we haven't had enough sleep but it
can also raise our blood pressure and
make us feel anxious it's the world's
most widely used drug so how does it
keep us awake
caffeine evolved in plants where it
serves a few purposes in high doses as
it's found in the leaves and seeds of
certain species it's toxic to insects
but when they consume it in lower doses
as its found in nectar it can actually
help them remember and revisit flowers
in the human body
caffeine acts as a stimulant for the
central nervous system it keeps us awake
by blocking one of the body's key sleep
inducing molecules a substance called
adenosine your body needs a constant
supply of energy which it gets by
breaking down a high-energy molecule
called ATP in the process it liberates
adenosine ATP's chemical backbone
neurons in your brain have receptors
perfectly tailored to this molecule when
adenosine docks to these receptors it
activates a cascade of biochemical
reactions that cause the neurons to fire
more sluggishly and slow the release of
important brain signaling molecules in
other words you get sleepy caffeine is
what's called an adenosine receptor
antagonist that means it derails this
process of slowing your neurons down by
blocking adenosine receptors caffeine
and adenosine have a similar molecular
structure close enough that caffeine can
wedge into the adenosine receptors but
not close enough to activate them
to summarize adenosine inhibits your
neurons caffeine inhibits the inhibitor
so it stimulates you caffeine can also
boost positive feelings in some neurons
the adenosine receptors are linked to
receptors for another molecule called
dopamine
one of dopamine's roles in the brain is
to promote feelings of pleasure when
adenosine docks in one of these paired
receptors that can make it harder for
dopamine to fit in its own spot
interrupting its mood lifting work but
when caffeine takes adenosine 'z place
it doesn't have the same effect and
dopamine can slide in there's evidence
that caffeine's effects on adenosine and
dopamine receptors can have long-term
benefits to reducing the risk of
diseases like Parkinson's Alzheimer's
and some types of cancer caffeine can
also ramp up the body's ability to burn
fat in fact some sports organizations
think that caffeine gives athletes an
unfair advantage and have placed limits
on its consumption from 1972 until 2004
olympic athletes had to stay below a
certain blood caffeine concentration to
compete of course not all of caffeine's
effects are so helpful it might make you
feel better and more alert but it can
also raise your heart rate and blood
pressure cause increase urination or
diarrhea and contribute to insomnia and
anxiety plus the foods and beverages
caffeine is found in have their own
impacts on your body that have to be
taken into account your brain can adapt
to regular consumption of caffeine if
your adenosine receptors are perpetually
clogged your body will manufacture extra
ones that way even with caffeine around
adenosine can still do its job of
signaling the brain to power down that's
why you may find you need to consume
more and more caffeine to feel as alert
there are more and more adenosine
receptors to block it's also why if you
suddenly quit caffeine you may
experience an
withdrawl with plenty of receptors and
no competition
adenosine can work overtime causing
symptoms like headaches tiredness and
depressed moods but in a few days the
extra adenosine receptors will disappear
your body will readjust and you'll feel
just as alert as ever
even without an infusion of the world's
most popular stimulant
[Music]
you